dr sika brown selected one reducted  brand bouncy ball for testing which came  with its cardboard label still attached  the ball was placed in the machinery on  the fine setting and produced a ball  with a label identifying it as an extra  bouncy ball this resulting ball was  placed back in the machine once again on  the fine setting it produced a smaller  ball in a different color with a label  calling it a super duper bouncy ball  this product does not appear to be sold  in stores the super duper bouncy ball  was placed in 914 on the setting very  fine no changes were made to its  appearance but when dr brown dropped the  ball its resulting bounce caused 45  casualties and propelled it out of the  earth's atmosphere currently it is  orbiting near mars